The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, what
we're going to do,
we're going to start our
story in what at the time
would have been called the
Northwest United States.
We're in the first
part of the 1800s,
and we're really talking
about this portion of it here.
Although later on in our
story, we'll actually
cover this whole region here.
This was a sparsely-populated,
impoverished area.
There were basically
no roads or towns.
There was lots of swamps,
mountains, rivers,
land transportation
was very difficult.
The area was more or less
under constant warfare
from 1800 till about 1880.
I'm talking about
large scale armies
in what would be called the
Indian Wars, but also smaller
scale raids of dozens
or half a dozen people,
and individual murders.
It was among the
poorest areas on earth.
Who lived there?
Anybody know?
So early 1800s, 1810, 1820 in
the Northwest United States?
AUDIENCE: No one?
PROFESSOR: Anybody?
No, people lived there.
AUDIENCE: People
looking for gold?
PROFESSOR: Gold miners
were a little bit later,
but sure, they would come along.
There were some Native
Americans, many of them
had been pushed from
other places, right?
The east coast Native Americans
had been pushed in there.
There were some Native
Americans that lived
there who were resisting that.
There were also Natives being
pushed in from the South
by the people in Mexico.
So we've got people being in.
How about Acadian Driftwood?
Anybody here--?
So the Canadian rebels,
who were French-speaking,
are being pushed
here by the English.
Whiskey Rebellion, right?
The rebellious people
in the United States
are being pushed out here,
escaped slaves, debtors.
There is an expression
at the time, GTT.
If you didn't want
to pay your debts,
you wrote GTT on your door.
It meant "Gone To Texas,"
and you headed over here.
So we got this area full of
losers, violence, very little
in the way of
economic resources.
A few years ago, somebody did
a list of the 100 wealthiest
Americans of all time.
And they compared it.
They tried to estimate
the wealth of these people
and they compared it to the
total size of the economy
at the time.
19 of the 100 wealthiest
Americans of all time
were in that Northwest
area in 1850,
and they made their money
from about 1850 to 1880.
So what happened?
How did this poor economic
place with no prospects
for anything, the last place in
the world you'd expect anybody
to get rich, how did it generate
such tremendous fortunes?
And it isn't just money.
I mean you say, OK,
well, some of them
struck gold or oil or
something like that.
But listen to the names.
It wasn't just robber barons
like Rockefeller, Mellon,
and Carnegie.
It was great inventors like
McCormick, Westinghouse,
and Pullman.
Innovators in other fields,
such as Swift, Pulitzer, Hearst,
Armor, Marshall Field.
These people are
household names today.
I challenge anybody in this
room to name any other business
innovator anywhere in the
world in the entire 1900s.
OK, so we got 19 of them
in this little area.
And we know them today, right?
None anywhere else.
There were some innovations
in other places,
but here was clearly the
place where modern business
was being formed.
So what was it that they had?
Was it something in the water?
Something in the air?
What did this region have
that nobody else had?
AUDIENCE: Labor?
PROFESSOR: No, it was
very sparsely populated.
Labor was extremely expensive.
And your laborers had to
spend most of their time
eking out subsistence
living, right?
It would be very expensive
to bring in food or supplies
for them.
No, labor was
extremely expensive.
Well, I'll tell you
one thing they had was
they had a game called poker.
[LAUGHTER IN AUDIENCE]
All right, you're laughing.
I hope you won't be
laughing at the end of this.
Let's go back.
The first written records we
have from outside this region
about poker come to us
from about the late 1820s
and the early 1830s.
It's a lot more
interesting what they
don't say than what they say.
One thing they don't say
is, people in this region
played this game called poker,
and here's how it works.
None of them explain
the game at all.
That's kind of strange, right?
Somebody comes and
tells you, hey, there's
this game people
are playing here,
but they don't
tell you the rules.
They didn't even
describe it as a game.
The one thing they
were very clear about
is it involved transferring
large amounts of money.
They also-- nobody said, oh,
it's a variant of this game
or that game somebody
plays somewhere else.
Nobody said, this is some game
you might be interested in.
Everybody already knew.
I mean, it was-- you
can read these things.
It was common knowledge
that people in this area
played a game called poker.
It was a very serious game
played for very large amounts
of money.
It was played nowhere else.
Nobody mentioned
any antecedents.
Nobody said it was brought in
by the French or by the Indians
or by the Persians or
by any other group.
It was just there.
It was there in the area.
A couple other interesting
things about this game.
First of all, what we know that,
far more popular than poker
at any period of time, and
certainly in this period
as well, were standard
gambling games
that are played--
variants of which
are played all over the world
by people of all classes.
Dice games, faro
was very popular
at the time, wheel-based
chance games.
We also know though, the
other kind of game people
were familiar with is played by
aristocrats-- things like whist
or chess-- that don't
necessarily involve gambling,
although they can, and
involve a lot of skill.
Poker was neither of the above.
OK, so let's start
asking, what is there
about poker that was
different from any game that
came before it?
This might give us some clue
as to why this was different.
What was going on here?
Ace beats king.
OK, that doesn't
seem like much today.
That was pretty
revolutionary, right?
You'd go to get executed in
most countries in the world
in those days for saying that.
And an ace was, by the
way, in early poker,
ace was always high.
There was no such thing
as a low/high ace.
So that tells you something.
OK, the people who
made this game,
they weren't monarchists, right?
They were thinking
a different way.
Here's another thing, though.
The hand rankings are
in order of rarity.
The rarer the hand,
the higher it ranks.
And in early poker, we didn't
have straights and flushes,
so it's even more
straightforward.
But here's something
kind of interesting.
Here's something that
changed in the game.
So in the early poker up
until about the 1830s,
this principle that
the rarer the hand,
the more valuable it was was
actually employed much more
consistently.
So today when you
compare two hands that
are of the same
time-- so two people
each have two pair,
two people each
have a pair, two people
each have a nothing hand.
You decide the winner starting
from the highest cards on down.
Right, so if I have two
pair and you have two pair,
we first look at who has
the higher highest pair.
Then we look at who
has the higher lowest
pair if that's a tie.
But in early poker,
it was reversed.
And you can see if you rank
it the way we do today,
we've inverted our principle.
Now, the more common the
hand-- like ace high hands,
there are 500,000 out
of the 1.3 million.
These are hands with no
straight, no flush, no pair,
no match.
The ace high hands
are the most common,
but they rank the highest.
In poker up till about,
like I say, the 1830s,
we ranked it by the
lowest card in the hand.
So you first compared
your lowest card, then
your second lowest.
And there you see we are
true to the principle
that the rarer the hand,
the higher it ranks.
Can anybody see the strategic
difference this makes?
Why is this important?
Is it just completely arbitrary?
What difference does it make?
Let's say we did things
this way in poker.
What difference would
it make to the play?
What it means is aces
are much less valuable.
It's a lot like-- anybody
here every play lowball poker?
Lowball poker, your best
cards don't help you.
The question is,
what's your worst card?
You talk about a
lowball hand, you
talk about the highest card
in my hand that makes it.
You can have four great
cards, and a fifth card
can completely ruin it.
You can ace, king, queen,
jack and then a two,
and you've got a two low hand,
and you lose to everybody else.
In the modern poker,
if you have an ace--
let's say we both have
hands and neither one of us
has any matches or
straight or flush.
If I have an ace, I have an
83% chance that I beat you.
But if we rank them
by low card, an ace
only gives you a 56%
chance of winning.
An ace is much less valuable
because really the difference
between ace, king,
queen, and jack
is very little, because
it's your lowest card that's
going to determine how
strong your hand is.
Now, the biggest point I
want to make about this
isn't the subtleties
of a strategy
when you rank hands this way.
This is a game
that was designed.
This is a game that somebody
thought about, articulated
a rational principle, and
did what was at the time
some pretty clever mathematics
to figure out the ranking.
This is not a game that
evolved by long tradition.
This is not a game where
somebody in a court
sat down and wrote the rules.
This is a game that
somebody designed,
and they designed
it for a reason.
But actually, the
card playing poker
is pretty trivially simple,
and especially straight poker.
It was called straight
poker at the time.
The way the game was played
was you were dealt a card,
you had a betting round, you
were dealt a second card,
you had a betting around.
You were dealt a third card,
you had a betting round,
and then that was
the last round.
The last two
cards-- at the time,
they were called the
turn and the river,
just like in hold 'em
today-- were dealt together,
and there was no betting
after the final card.
I'll tell you why that's
important in a bit.
Another thing about the
way the betting was done
is there was no ante.
There was no blind in the
sense we know it today.
The way the betting
worked-- and again, this
shows some very careful
design on somebody's part--
the dealer dealt the cards.
The person to the dealer's
left was known as the age.
The age posted a
stake, and they could
post any, before they saw
their card, their first card.
They could post a stake,
any amount they wanted,
including zero.
They didn't have
to post anything.
But the rules were
a little different.
On the first-- and this is
only on the first round.
All the subsequent
rounds, the betting
is exactly the same
as modern poker.
But on the first
round, you were not
allowed to call the age's bet.
So let's say the age bets $1.
You cannot call that.
You can fold, or you can raise.
And the minimum raises the
amount to the minimum bet
would be $2.
So this gives a
lot more advantage
to the age compared
to somebody who
posts a blind today, a
blind that can be called.
In a way, you can
see the analogy
between what the age does
and what the small blind does
in poker, that somebody has
to double the bet in order
to play.
Although in modern poker, with
a small blind and a big blind,
someone is forced to
come in and double.
The poker players at the
time were very insistent.
They said poker is not gambling.
And the difference
between poker and gambling
is no one is ever
forced to make a bet.
You look at your
cards, you voluntarily
make a bet that you
think has-- they wouldn't
use the word at the time,
but we would say now
is that you think has
positive expected value.
The first, the blind
bet, was empirically
known to be a winning.
It was an advantage
people posted.
Now mathematically, you can
show that can't be true.
But psychologically
and empirically,
it was true, that posting the
blind with other people being
forced to either double or fold
was empirically an advantage.
Anyone else betting,
they could bet
if they thought they would win.
They didn't have to
bet if they didn't.
So let's talk about
the betting in poker.
There are a couple
of things about it
that are different from any
other game that comes before.
The first one is that at the
end of every betting round,
everyone remaining in the hand
has bet exactly the same amount
of money.
The hand is mark-to-market
after every round.
So ultimately,
you're betting on who
has the best hand
at showdown, or who
has the best surviving
hand at showdown of people
who haven't folded.
But in between the way,
at the end of every round,
the game cannot continue until
everyone remaining in the hand
has bet the same amount.
This didn't last all that long.
So by the 1840s,
1850s, we're saying
there's a lot of fight against
these very strict rules.
People started adding antes.
People started adding
straights and flushes.
People started adding betting
after the final round of cards.
People started adding all kinds
of more complicated games--
draw poker, stud poker
with some cards revealed.
They started adding
new kinds of hands.
So the game starts to
change a little bit.
And R.F. Foster,
who was probably
one of the first
people to really write
a comprehensive
history of poker--
and this was 100
years later, really--
explained what happened.
So there is this
conservative, old game,
scientific based on
very rigid principles,
that eventually evolved
into the modern game.
The modern game, a
lot more fun to play.
The modern game allows
gambling, clearly.
The modern game is really for
a somewhat different purpose.
But so far, we've
talked about the cards
and we've talked
about the betting.
We actually haven't talked about
the most revolutionary thing
in poker that, again, is like no
other game that came before it.
Most gambling games throughout
history-- and remember,
gambling goes back
to human prehistory.
Virtually every culture
has forms of gambling.
But gambling is almost always
done for either goods or cash.
When credit was used, credit
was provided by a trusted
central counterparty.
So somebody who organized the
game might organize credit.
Poker was never played for
cash, never played for goods.
Poker was played
for what were called
at the time "poker checks."
And this is a distinction
that goes all the way up
to about the 1980s before
it finally got erased.
Even as late as the 1980s
when I was playing poker,
there was a distinction,
and people understood it.
There were two similar things
that were often confused.
There were checks,
and there were chips.
And they looked kind of similar.
A check had intrinsic value.
Checks were used for cash.
Casino checks were used
for cash in Las Vegas.
Nobody ever used cash.
You just used casino chips
for all your transactions.
But they were also used for
all different kinds of games.
Chips are just markers.
Chips are things you
buy at the table,
and you're supposed to cash them
in when you leave the table.
You're not even supposed to take
them from the roulette table
over to the craps table
or something like that.
So chips are just markers.
They have no intrinsic value.
There is a complicated
story which
I'd be happy to talk to
you people about sometime.
The IRS came down.
And some casinos, when they
pushed organized crime out,
they got rid of checks.
So right now, there's no such
thing as, a least a legal,
chip with a real,
intrinsic value.
They're just markers.
If you show up to a
casino with a $5,000 chip
and you want to
cash it in, they're
going to ask you
where you got it,
prove that you bought it at a
Casino or won it at a casino.
If you can't, they won't
give you any money for it.
But let's go back
to the early 1800s.
The way poker was played
was with poker checks.
Poker checks were markers.
Often, they were
made out of clay.
People would make little
disks out of clay,
and they would put
a thumb print in it.
They would put some
identifiable marker.
The key thing is that they were
identifiable to an individual.
You were playing poker with
money you created yourself.
And if you lost, other people
would have these markers,
and these markers
would be claims on you.
If you won, you had
other people's markers.
At the end of the
game, people did
something called ring
clearing, which means, oh, OK.
You played a game for a while.
You've got a bunch of
checks in front of you.
You're going to take the checks
you have from other people,
you're going to trade them
for your own checks back.
You're going to end up
with, if you were a winner,
you're going to end up with a
bunch of other people's checks,
and suddenly a bunch of
people owe you money.
Or if you were a
loser, other people
are going to end up with yours.
But it's a winners
responsibility
to collect from the losers.
There's no central counterparty.
There's no trusting.
You play.
If you don't like a
guy's checks, too bad.
You got some things that
aren't-- maybe you can find
somebody else to trade
you something for them.
Now what you've done is you've
created a form of money.
It's this credit creation that
is a really essential element
of early poker.
And let's talk about another
financial institution
from this period-- the
soft money bank, otherwise
called a wildcat bank.
People created banks.
And the way they created
banks is somebody said,
I have a bank, and I'm
going to make loans.
And I'll either print up some
bank notes, some of which
were extremely crude.
People even used markers,
twigs, old tally sticks,
things like that.
They used anything they
could find as bank notes.
Or they just kept an
accounting system.
If you want to spend
the money, somebody
has to deposit it into the bank.
If it worked, this generated
a lot of economic activity.
Everything was successful.
The loans paid off.
Deposits were honored.
Everything was fine.
If it didn't work,
everything was worthless.
If you add one
feature to this, it
comes what most people
think of as a bank.
The one feature we're missing
from this bank is what?
Actual money, gold.
Right.
Now, this is kind of an
interesting dichotomy
in economics.
To me, a classic bank
is a soft money back.
Capital, to me, is an
additional feature that gives it
some credibility, right?
It means two things.
It means the person
creating the bank
is going to have some
skin in the game,
is going to take a loss if the
whole bank collapses, if nobody
ever pays back their loans.
So that shows-- it's a signal to
show they have some confidence.
Also, the cash they put in, the
capital they put in, in theory
is going to help people
if the bank fails.
It'll pay off some
portion of the losses.
In practice, it never does.
In practice, the people
who run the banks always
get their capital out
before anybody else.
But a lot of the legislation
on banks, a lot of the way
people think about
banks, is the opposite.
They think about it as a
classic bank is something
that has 100% capital, and
that fractional reserve
is some kind of like little
extra thing you do to a bank.
But we see, if you look again,
human prehistory cultures,
you see almost all cultures have
some form of this self credit
equation, all kinds of things--
susus, tontines, [INAUDIBLE].
All over the world, we
have these kinds of things,
and they were useful
in the American West.
Well, poker was one of them.
Poker was a way you could
create a form of money,
your own money.
You could play a game.
If you won, you picked up a lot
of credit from other people,
and you could use
that to generate
some economic activity.
If you lost, other people
had to employ you, right?
They had to get their
money back somehow.
You didn't have any money.
They had to find
things for you to do
to work in their businesses.
And this is how
a lot of business
was created in the old west.
Now we're going to move a little
forward to around the 1840s.
Anyone know what this is?
It is the Chicago
Board of Trade.
This is actually around 1900,
so it wouldn't be quite so fancy
back in 1840.
Futures exchanges,
again, appeared
in exactly the same geographic
area as the game of poker
about 20 years later.
Nobody invented it.
Suddenly, these things started
popping up all over the place.
A financial institution
no one had ever
seen before, completely
unlike anything in the past,
none of them outside the region,
ubiquitous inside the region,
and nobody said
they invented it.
There was something
in the culture,
in the way people thought, the
way people did business that
made this a very
natural thing to do,
even though it had
never been done before.
And the analogies with poker
are pretty obvious, right?
Mark-to-market.
Every day, you're betting on the
price of wheat in three months,
but every day you settle up so
that you got the same amount
of money at stake.
Clearing-- again, the initial
exchanges in the early days,
they used ring clearing,
exactly the same as poker.
Later on, they went to
a full clearinghouse
that was a little
more sophisticated
and allowed people to do it.
But what's the purpose
of these exchanges?
What does this futures
exchange do for people?
AUDIENCE: To lock in the price.
PROFESSOR: Like who?
Who would want to
lock in a price?
AUDIENCE: The farmers.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, let's think about this.
I'm a farmer in 1840.
I'm about a two-week journey
from Chicago over bad roads.
Normally, I do what farmers
have done since the beginning
of private agriculture.
They would sell to a crop buyer.
I would go to the place
where I buy my supplies,
and there's a crop buyer
who has an agent there,
or that agent also comes by
my farm every month or so
to check out how the crops
are going, because he wants
to keep tabs on the crops.
And also, I can lock
in a price with him.
He will buy exactly my crop.
He will buy whatever
quantity I happen to produce.
He'll agree on a price now,
or he'll set the price later.
Whatever I want.
I deliver it.
I can deliver it to him, or
for a slightly lower price,
he'll come and pick
it up at my farm.
Now let's compare
that with this futures
exchange, a brand
new innovation that's
going to make my life better.
I can take a two-week
journey into Chicago.
I can promise to
delivery set quantity
of a set grade of wheat that
I don't produce that I can't
be sure I will have on time.
I don't know the quantity
I'm going to produce,
but I have to specify that.
I have to put down
initial margin.
I don't have any cash.
All my cash is
tied up in my crop.
Farmers only have
cash after harvest.
And I have to stay
in Chicago every day
to make mark-to-market payments,
since who's growing my wheat?
OK, so this makes
absolutely no sense.
Anytime you read
a textbook and it
talks about farmers
using futures exchanges,
you know they haven't spent half
a second thinking about this.
There were no farmers
involved in setting up
the futures exchanges.
In fact, farmers were
suspicious and have often
tried to have them shut down.
When farmers do use
futures exchanges,
they almost always
buy the product.
They don't sell it.
So let's talk about what people
really use these things for.
Here is the canonical
trade that you
can think about, what you want
to understand futures markets.
I'm a processor.
All the people who
set these things up--
and by the why, all the
people who set these things up
were poker players.
I'm not kidding.
Look it up, you
find the name, you
find all these people
were poker players.
I grind wheat, OK?
I'm not going to use
this for hedging.
I can't use it for
hedging, right?
I buy wheat, that's true.
But is my exposure to
wheat going up in price
or going down in price?
One going up.
OK, let me tell you two stories.
Story number one,
there's a sudden increase
in demand for wheat.
There's a big war in
Europe, other crops
fail in other regions.
The price of wheat goes way up.
What happens to my business?
I'm making lots of money, right?
They've got to
grind lots of wheat.
They're bringing all the wheat
in from all the [INAUDIBLE].
Everybody grinds it, there's a
shortage of grinding capacity,
I can raise my prices.
I'm rich.
So it that way, I'm
long wheat, right?
Price of wheat goes up,
my business goes up.
Let's say-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: So you're
assuming that the price
of grounded wheat is directly
correlated to the price
of wheat?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I'm saying the price of
ground wheat is what went up.
And because the price
of ground wheat went up,
my business is more valuable.
And you're exactly-- you
hit the point exactly,
if that's the stuff I'm selling.
Now let's do a different story.
There's a crop
failure in the area.
Price of wheat
goes way up, right?
Wheat is scarce.
Who wants my
grinding facilities?
Nobody.
There's an excess of
grinding facilities.
I can't charge a penny.
OK, so I have no
natural wheat exposure.
I can't hedge my wheat exposure
in this futures market.
Also, for the same reasons
I mentioned of a farmer,
it's not a convenient
place to do it.
It's a type and grade
of wheat I don't
want at a place I don't want.
Also, the price of
wheat has very little
do with my business.
What I care about is my
machinery operating properly,
what's the price of fuel,
what's the price of labor, what
are the regulations
on the stuff, what's
the equality of the
stuff I'm getting.
I can lock in prices with
suppliers and either buyers
or the flour or sellers of
the wheat anytime I want.
That's not the point
of the futures market.
What you want to think
about is I'm growing wheat.
I'm going to go to a
silo, a grain silo.
A grain silo is a guy, he buys
wheat from all over the place
and he sells it
to people like me.
I'm going to say, OK,
I want these wheat
deliveries over the
next three months,
so much and so on
these various times.
I want it delivered to
my grinding facility.
I want exactly this
type and kind of wheat.
And he'll agree, and
we'll settle a deal.
Now I'm going to go to
the futures exchange.
I've just bought a
quarter's worth of wheat
from the wheat silo.
I'm going to go to
the futures exchange,
I'm going to sell a quarter's
worth of wheat forward.
What have I done?
Well, now I have no
price risk, right?
Now if the price of
wheat goes up or down,
I don't care, because
I bought we today,
and I sold it three
months from now.
I have borrowed wheat.
Now, what could I do instead?
I could borrow money.
I could borrow money
and buy the wheat.
But then I take
two price risks--
I take the price risk of
the money, and remember,
this is an area where there's
very little money around.
These futures
exchanges were invented
in a place where there was
very little gold and silver.
There wasn't a good
banking system.
Bank notes weren't
very trustworthy.
So taking the risk of
money was a big risk.
And also, price of
wheat going up and down.
The simplest thing is
just to borrow wheat,
which is what I want to do.
And like any business loan,
I never intend to repay this.
If I'm doing a business
loan, say to buy machinery,
I make the loan.
And when the loan comes
due, I borrow again
to run the business.
The only time I pay
back my business loans
is when I shut down the business
and liquidate everything
and pay off the creditors.
Same thing with this.
I'm going to roll these futures
contracts forward forever.
I'm never going
to take delivery.
But what I've done is I've
perpetually borrowed wheat.
I've taken part of
my business input
and I borrowed it
instead of buying it.
So one thing is the
futures exchanges create
a tremendous amount of credit.
But they do something else too
that's kind of interesting.
Anybody here know how to
take flour and turn it back
into wheat?
Anybody here know how
to take August wheat
and move it back in time to May?
All right, I have something
very surprising to tell you.
For 175 years, the
Chicago Board of Trade
here has been quoting prices
on both of those services.
A futures exchange quotes
prices on services nobody's
ever thought of.
It opens tremendous
scope for innovation.
Let's say I want
to build a bridge.
And when I build
this bridge, it's
going to divert wheat that
was going to Saint Louis.
It's going to get diverted
to Chicago, because now it's
going to be cheaper to
move it into Chicago.
I can hedge that.
I can sell those transportation
services on the futures market
by buying Chicago wheat and
selling Saint Louis wheat.
I can do calendar spreads.
I can do grade spreads, cleaning
spreads, all of these things
are a way of buying and selling
all the services involved
in an agricultural
processing business.
And this turns out to be
a far more efficient way
to organize things.
It's got its internally
generated credit.
It's got far better
information flows.
And this is what touches
off a tremendous explosion
of business activity and
business innovation that
goes throughout the world.
Now, one of the things that's
kind of strange about futures
markets is they were only used
for agricultural commodities.
Now, granted, that was a much
bigger part of the economy
than it is today, but
in the global economy,
this was not a big deal.
There were much, much more
valuable commodities that never
went to futures exchanges.
And there were things--
commodities weren't even
the most valuable things.
When things really took
off is in the 1970s
when people took the same idea
and moved it to financial.
But my story is about poker.
One of the things
people sometimes
say is that futures evolved
from to arrive contracts.
Now, to arrive contracts
have been around longer
than we have written records.
In ancient Mesopotamia
in the early days,
we see in the earliest writings
that we can still read today,
we find that these to arrive
contracts were common.
A to arrive contract
says, essentially,
I will sell you 10,000 bushels
of wheat at $0.50 a bushel
as soon as wheat
comes to the market,
wheat come to the city market.
OK, it's a price guarantee.
It's not a delivery guarantee.
I don't tell you when
you're going to get it.
I don't even guarantee
you will get it.
I'm just saying,
when it comes, this
is what I will sell it you at.
The largest to arrive
market in the United States
was in Buffalo.
OK, everybody remember all
those stories about the fortunes
won and lost on the
Buffalo to arrive
exchange, the
fistfights, the corners?
We had people who made
their fortunes there, never
went on do anything else?
Exactly.
To arrive contracts are run
by quiet commission clerks.
Futures exchanges are populated
by tough, brawling innovators
who often make fortunes
or lose fortunes and go on
to do dramatic
business activity.
There's no connection
between the two.
Now, can anybody tell me which
ones of these are poker games?
AUDIENCE: Omaha.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Omaha, Texas.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Chicago.
PROFESSOR: Chicago, yes.
This one you guys might
not have heard of so much,
but there is a Cincinnati.
It isn't played much anymore.
There is no poker
game called Buffalo.
There is no poker game named
after any place except places
where, if you lose all
your money in the game,
drown your servers by
jumping in a river,
you float down to New Orleans.
Even today, poker is very,
very strongly regionally-- it's
a regional attitude.
It's an extraordinarily
explosive innovative
economic attitude, and it
has never really seeped out
except the place it was born.
Now, that may no longer be
true with internet poker.
The question is, is the
soul of poker alive?
Internet poker has this economic
innovation and freedom and self
credit creation.
Is this something's that's going
to spread to the whole world,
or has somehow poker
been neutralized
and, when it comes to a
computer and becomes virtual,
it's no longer got that soul?
It's something we're going to
find out in the next few years.
Now we're going to
jump forward to me.
I was born in the 1950s.
I was raised in Seattle.
And one thing you
have to understand
is two people can be raised in
exactly the same time, exactly
the same environment, and have
totally different ideas of what
it was like.
I think most people
would say, if a movie was
made of my childhood,
they would say, hey,
that was an idyllic childhood.
Your dad was a professor.
You didn't have so
much money that you
had affluenza and were wrecking
cars or things like that.
But you were never
embarrassed that you
didn't have clothes for
school, you were never hungry,
anything like that.
You were treated well.
It was a suburban neighborhood.
It was a pretty place.
You had lots of stimulation,
all of that stuff.
But I hated it.
I was oppressed
by lots of things.
I believed, I
sincerely believed,
that the world was going
to end in nuclear war
before I was in college.
It just seemed like it
clearly was likely to happen.
I was interested in
math and science,
but all the math and
science was defense related.
Only big government
projects to kill
people were the only way you
could get funding for things.
More than half the world was in
the grip of brutal totalitarian
dictatorships, and no country
had ever emerged from communism
to freedom and prosperity.
It seemed like the entire,
world even the free world, even
the relative democracies,
were run by paranoids
and total incompetents.
The economy was terrible.
Seattle was a few years ahead
of the rest of the country
and we had sort of slipped
into that '70s malaise
back in the '60s.
A friend of the family who
was an aerospace engineer who
was the world expert--
in fact, he went to MIT.
He was the world expert in
materials for supersonic wing
design.
He was fired because
nobody wanted
to build supersonic planes,
and he was driving a cab.
Another thing about this
is this is, again, Seattle
was kind of forward looking
in terms of economics.
We were getting economic malaise
before the rest of the country.
In another way, we were
kind of a throwback.
It was more like the '50s than
other parts of the country.
And it was this really
weird social dynamic.
OK, I don't want to tell you
the neighborhood I grew up
in was any worse or weirder
than any other neighborhood.
But there was a certain
percentage of alcoholics,
or child molesters,
of wife beaters,
of drug addicts, all the stuff.
And in the '50s and in Seattle
by the time I was growing up,
nobody cared about it.
Nobody would ever talk
about any of that stuff.
If a man cut his grass and
brought home a paycheck,
he was a good guy.
He could do anything else and
nobody would talk about it.
But if you didn't--
and we would have this.
It would happen.
Like a neighbor, the
guy would lose this job.
They would quietly move
away, and nobody would ever
talk about them.
It was just weird.
And you got the message, OK,
the economy was very insecure.
If you could earn money,
everything was fine.
You didn't have to worry
about anything else.
But if you couldn't earn
money, it was unspeakably bad.
Well, I was a shy kid.
I was introverted, awkward.
But I liked looking in the back
of a newspaper at the numbers.
The patterns in the numbers
really fascinated me.
And I worked out ways, and
I would bet money on horses,
I would bet money
on other sports.
And I found out I
could win doing this.
I also found out-- and this was
true throughout the American
West at the time.
I couldn't really find
a good picture of this.
This is just something I
found on the internet that's
roughly equivalent.
Taverns, in the back
room of the taverns
or the basement of the taverns,
there were these poker games.
And I'd go in and I'd
play, and I'd win.
And more important than that
I would win, I could walk in.
I could collect the money.
I could walk out, and this was
enormously liberating to me.
It said to me, OK.
You don't have to get a job.
You don't have to go to college.
Anywhere you go in the world,
you can find a poker game.
You can win money.
And when you're a good
player and people know it,
even if you run out of
money, people lend you money.
People stake you.
You also start getting
into this network.
And this was something I
had not expected at all.
I had gone there, I thought, OK.
I'm going to win
some money, and I'm
going to prove that I can
get this monkey off my back
and I don't have to
worry about this anymore.
These people-- the
people I was playing with
didn't look like this.
One or two of them might
have looked like this.
But there were policemen,
there were sailors,
there were clerks.
You know, people.
And they end up owing you money.
Right, if you're good
player, these people
end up owing you money.
And I later kind of
figured, I sort of
had a half idea of what
was going on at the time.
But I've later figured
it out a little better,
and later in life as
I've played more places,
I've figured out the
system a little better.
I had a purpose
for these people.
I had two purposes.
One is because I was a good
player I protected their game.
Let's say somebody showed
up, a really good player
wanted to take all
their money, show up
and-- well, they had
somebody there who was good.
And by the way, being a good
poker player in those days
didn't just mean good card play.
In fact, it would be trivially--
and I'm sure anybody here
what have no trouble cleaning
up in terms of pure card play
in this game.
But you had to be
able to spot cheating.
You had to be able to figure
out who might risk of arrest.
You had to figure out
who might get violent.
I mean, there's a lot of
social skills involved in this.
So by being a good player,
you protected the game,
but you also connected
them with a bigger network.
So remember, a lot of this
is about credit equation.
A tremendous amount of
economic activity goes on here.
There's doctors, lawyers,
police, mechanics,
whatever-- people exchanging
services, underground economy,
people who couldn't make
it in the normal economy.
Like let's say you're a lawyer,
and you're a really bad lawyer.
And you can't get any business.
You hang [? out a shingle, ?]
nobody's going to hire you.
Your resume isn't very good.
There's too many lawyers around.
But you know, you owe
somebody money at a poker game
and they want you to write a
letter and do some for them,
whenever, you can do a little
legal business on this stuff.
And by connecting into the
broader network in the city,
you connect these people in.
Some of these people had really
dropped out of normal life,
or they weren't
getting paychecks.
They were subsisting entirely
on the underground economy.
And this was a very important
organizational tool.
Other people like
to keep one foot
in that world-- maybe a
little side income, maybe
a little fallback.
We weren't doing like
big organized crime,
but there'd be a
sailor in the game who
could bring in Cuban cigars.
There was a guy who
was maybe a bathroom
attendant at a fancy
restaurant who could sell them,
and this kind of stuff could get
organized in a game like this.
The poker was very important
because you actually
spend a lot of time
with these people.
You learned a lot about them.
You couldn't fake it in a way.
An undercover cop could
show up for two days
or act something
this, but they aren't
going to be playing poker
every day for years.
So I'm kind of moving up in
the Seattle poker network,
and I come to Boston.
I went to Harvard.
And again, remember, I'm shy.
I'm awkward.
I'm from the west, a little
overwhelmed by all this stuff.
But I walked in with a network.
It shocked me when I got
here that this network was
seamlessly translated across
the country, that I knew police,
I knew poker people of all
different ranks and stations
of life.
I got into poker games
at Harvard itself.
People talk about going to
college to get contacts.
Let me tell you about that.
I had three roommates.
I love my roommates.
These are great guys.
I'm not saying anything
bad about them.
But in terms of like useful
contacts for me in life,
well, one of them's a
corporate lawyer, one of them's
a TV producer, one of
them's a law professor--
all great things, that's nice.
Never really a lot
of use to me in terms
of advancing my business
interests or whatever,
and not exactly hard things
to break into, right?
You want to know a
corporate lawyer?
Well, it's pretty easy to
know a corporate lawyer.
Poker games at Harvard, I
played with George W. Bush,
who went on to be president.
I played with Bill Gates,
Steve Ballmer, Scott Turow,
people who are celebrities,
politicians, rich people.
Those are the poker connections.
And a poker connection
is very different.
You're not playing
poker with your friends.
A poker connection is,
there is a business
relationship in there that
can be extremely useful.
My whole life, my
whole career, has been
informed by poker networks.
Now I'm going to zip
through a few things.
I'm playing in Boston,
a guy shows up.
He actually managed a card
room near Stanford University.
He was, again, it's
this network thing.
So I'm playing now in a
pretty senior game in Boston,
some the best card
players in Boston
are here, pretty high stakes.
And they invite visiting pros
from other parts of the country
to keep the network connected
throughout the country.
And this guy said to me,
he said, well, I was good.
I played well that night.
But it wasn't just that.
He said, you know, you're
a kind of strange guy.
You've got this sort of
mathematical poker sense.
You think about it in
theoretical terms, whatever.
There are a lot of guys like
you out in Gardena, California.
So that's where the best poker
in the world is being played.
He said, I'm a good player.
I'm a national pro.
I go around from city to
city sitting in end games
with the best
players in the city.
And I win in those games, but I
can't turn a profit in Gardena.
You should go the Gardena and
see if you can match yourself
up with the best.
So I go there.
How many people have heard
of Gardena, California?
Yeah.
If you're interested, there's
a movie called California Split
that's got some good scenes.
It's stupid poker movie
for the most part,
but it has some actual scenes
shot in Gardena at that time.
That was the best
poker in the world.
And it was the network theory
I was talking about on steroids
because of a few things.
First of all, this
is in the late '70s.
Marginal tax rates have
gotten really high,
regulation has gotten
crazy, the tax code
is incredibly
complicated and corrupt.
Community property, big
thing-- a lot of these guys
were wiped out in a divorce.
I mean, that was
something that just
didn't happen 10 years earlier.
A lot of them had tax liens.
So you have this whole group
of people, they tend be-- they
were much better
educated than the guys
I was playing with in Seattle or
even really the guys in Boston.
They were smart.
Not only were they broke,
they were financially toxic.
Any money they put
in a bank was getting
whisked away by somebody.
If they were walking down the
street with $1 in their pocket,
somebody could grab it.
Poker chip, not so much, right?
Poker debt, they lent some money
to somebody in the poker room,
nobody could collect that.
Tremendous about of very active
underground economy going on.
I go there, and first day I'm
there, guy comes up to me.
He manages a motel.
He used to own
it, went bankrupt.
Now the bank pays
him to manage it.
If you're a poker player, he'll
give you a room to stay in.
You have to pay.
You slip him a
little bit of money,
much less than
the rent would be.
It's kind of furnished with
broken down stuff other tenants
have left.
But poker players
don't care, right?
Poker players are
there, they go,
they sleep on the broken
couch, and then they leave.
Maybe take a shower if
it's the first of the month
or something.
And you'd stay there for
three or four months,
and eventually the owners
would kick you out.
And he'd just say, oh, well,
the guy never paid any rent,
and he would cover all
this for you and do it.
And then you just move to
the next motel down the line,
and he moves somebody else in.
You wanted to get
your car fixed,
you wanted to get
a lawsuit filed,
your operation done,
whatever, there were people
in the room to do it,
all for under the table,
you could borrow the money.
And all of the people who can
invented the modern poker,
if you talk about the David
Sklansky's, Mason Malmuth, Mike
Harrow.
I don't know if these
names mean anything to you,
but these were the first people
who actually sat down and wrote
poker theory books.
This was the only place
where people were really
thinking about it.
Las Vegas, they hated poker.
Casinos hate poker.
The reason casinos hated poker
is somebody in the building
was losing money and the
Casino wasn't getting it.
And they would stick it-- they
either wouldn't have poker,
or they'd stick it next to
the layout of slot machines
under the stairs.
They'd open and close the
room at random intervals.
The one thing they did was
the World Series of Poker.
It was a pure Casino
publicity stunt.
It had nothing to do
with poker in those days.
Only in like the late
'90s, early 2000s
with lots of people
being brought in
by internet, with
the poker boom,
with television did casinos
really come to terms with it
and start liking poker.
But Gardena was pure
poker, and that's
where the good stuff was done.
Now, I'm making my
living by poker.
But I have broader interests.
I'm thinking-- I was really,
when I came to Boston for four
years, I was shocked at
how shoddy I felt that most
quantitative analysis was.
I thought, people
are doing this work.
They're teaching this stuff.
They're advising the government.
They're running the government.
They're writing these
papers, this and that.
They have terrible data.
They have really
stupid analysis.
And the biggest thing, the
way I kind of encapsulated
all of this is, none
of them would bet
a nickel on their own results.
Every single one of them,
if they were buying a car,
they would spend a lot more
serious commonsense analysis
to get the right car
than they do recommending
a plan for the government to
take over the steel industry,
or something like that.
And a lot of other
people felt the same way.
And we had both
some philosophical
and some empirical
ideas that we were
sold on the idea of
quantitative analysis.
We were confident in our
ability to make bets and win.
One of the things about
hanging around with gamblers,
there's a lot of bets.
Gamblers are really
nasty people,
a lot of really bad stuff.
One of the flip
sides of that is you
don't have to be nice, which
takes a lot of pressure off.
But they do take things
seriously, right?
Anything you say, somebody
can say, put some money on it.
If you won't, you're just
an idiot loser chattering.
You'd start really thinking
about things if you actually
have to bet money on
anything, any opinion you get.
A lot of silly
chattering conversation
never happens if people have
to bet on everything they say.
Anyway though, the natural
thing to do is to say,
OK, I want to go to a place.
I want to prove that
my methods work.
And the way I'm going
to prove my methods work
is I'm going to go to
places where people gamble,
and I'm going to
prove that I can win.
Now, all of us had read Ed
Thorpe's Beat the Dealer.
Do people here know Ed Thorpe?
OK, you should.
You should read his books.
You should meet him.
He's still alive.
He was a mathematics professor.
He invented blackjack
card counting.
He managed to beat virtually
every other Casino game.
And he's also either invented
or perfected almost all
of the quantitative
hedge fund strategies
that people use today.
He was one of the most
successful hedge fund managers
for many years.
So one thing we did is we wanted
to go and beat casino games.
And then what I'd
like to talk about,
I'm just going to mention
this very briefly.
But roulette, to
me, was the one that
really changed the way I
think about a lot of stuff.
It's a very, very
important lesson
for people who have academic
statistics backgrounds.
How do you beat roulette?
OK, well this Ed Thorpe's.
Ed Thorpe was
thinking about this.
And he was hearing this
debate, and some people said,
you should [INAUDIBLE]
You should just
record the patterns
of the wheels
and see if you can notice
patterns, like the wheel's
a little weighted,
what number comes up
a little more than the others.
But other people said
no, that's impossible.
The wheels are too good.
And Ed had a really remarkable
insight that not enough people
know about.
He said, you can win
money either way.
If the wheel's broken and
13 comes up a little more
than it should,
you can bet on 13.
That's easy.
But if the wheel is so perfect
that every number comes
up equally often, it must
be machined to perfection,
then you can use
a little physics.
We had some mechanics up on
the board when I came here.
Use Newtonian physics, and
you can figure out where
the ball is going to end up.
So it's a lot of work.
He did it with Claude Shannon.
Again, we're back to
MIT, one of the fathers
of information theory.
And they sat down, and
they worked on roulette.
And if you study this
problem for a bit,
you pretty quickly find
out, here's how things work.
The way roulette works, they
spin a wheel in one direction,
and they spin a ball
around the outside
of a bowl the other way.
OK, everything is very Newtonian
until the ball goes away
from the edge.
It is very easy with a little
bit of electronic aids--
which at the time were
legal, and are now illegal.
But with electronic
aids, it's very easy
to tell what number
will be under the ball
when the ball leaves the edge.
Now, there's a lot of
bouncing and banging
around between that and
when the ball comes to rest.
And that's pretty
chaotic, essentially
impossible to predict.
So you have this perfectly
predictable section,
and then you have
this chaotic section.
But here's the insight.
The predictable section,
you can calculate.
You can know, OK.
You say, when the ball
goes under the edge,
number 17 will be
directly underneath it.
The chaotic part cannot
be uniform on the wheel.
You can say, if 17 is under
it when the ball comes down,
here is the
distribution of places
the ball is going to
end up on the wheel,
and it's nowhere near
random, nowhere near uniform.
So you can make good bets.
Now if you actually
want to do this,
you have to get several layers.
You have to keep
refining this notion.
But I just want to focus
on the big picture.
A lot of statistical theory,
the basic theory of statistics,
was based on dice.
That's what Nassim Taleb calls
the ludic fallacy-- people
trying to create randomness.
The real world is
nowhere near so random.
Even when people try to create
randomness, even in a Casino,
they can't do it.
And the reason they can't do it
is if you build things really,
really precisely,
they're predictable.
If you build things kind
of loose and sloppy,
they have non-uniform patterns.
What you can't do is build
a device that's both.
It exceeds human capabilities.
And when we're talking about
the practical randomness
you see in the world-- in the
stock market, in politics,
and in war, anything you
want to talk about-- people
are way too sloppy in
modeling things as random.
Whenever somebody says
this thing is random,
you say, I'm going
to take a hard block.
And I'm going to find little
pockets of predictability
that I can calculate.
And in between those
pockets of predictability,
I'm going to find patterns
that are non-uniform.
And what I'm going
to end up with is
I'm going to end up with a
system where people are saying,
you know, you're obsessing
about data and data quality
for things that don't
really matter very much.
Nobody else thinks these
statistics are important.
Why are you spending
all your time
cleaning data for
something that's
far removed from the essential
economics of this problem?
And they're also going
to say, and here are
the really important things.
And you're just
waving your hands.
You're not paying attention.
You're making criminally
reckless or crude assumptions
about those things.
But what they
don't understand is
that's exactly how you beat it.
That is what you do.
When you figure this stuff
out, you really come up
with this thing that will
understand and make a profit,
it will look like
that to outsiders,
that you're focused on
stuff that doesn't matter
and you're ignoring the
stuff that does matter.
Put another way,
the stuff you think
that matters doesn't,
and the stuff you
don't think that matters does.
And when you do enough
work on this kind of stuff,
that's how you win.
Now, the thing
about the people who
did blackjack card counting and
roulette and baccarat and craps
worked on all those
other games, what
happens when people find out
that's what they're doing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it depends
on the time and the place,
whether you're buried in the
desert or just warned off
or whatever.
But basically, you have
to fool the casino.
You're taking money
from the Casino.
The people who stuck with
this hate casinos a lot more
than they like money.
They tend to be
antisocial people.
You don't need any
social skills, right?
All you need is--
I mean, if you've
seen some of the movies, the
MIT blackjack team, Bring
Down the House,
whatever, you see
some wildly over the top
play acting to get things.
That isn't what most
of these guys were.
Most of these guys were quiet.
They went in, the
casino gets a game.
The casino takes care of stuff.
You just go in and play, but you
have to stay under the radar.
You can't let the casino notice.
Now, people also looked at
another field, sports betting.
Now, sports betting, this
is frequent of stuff.
This is Bayesian stuff.
It is a lot easier
to predict how
people are going to bet than
how a game is going to come out.
If you wanted to predictive
a game from first principles
and figure out what the
proper point spread was,
well, you've got a
big job ahead of you.
It can be done.
People have done it and made
some successful results,
but that's a big job.
Here's an easy observation
that was enough.
In the 1970s, this was
enough to make money.
Los Angeles Lakers
are a glamorous team.
They were at the time.
Los Angeles is a
big betting city.
When the Lakers play
at home, there's
a lot of money coming
in and betting on them.
The point spread is going
to be too favorable.
Bet against the
Lakers at home, right?
Don't need a genius,
don't need a math PhD,
don't need a computer.
You can just figure this out.
And patterns like this
are very easy to catch,
but they're based on
understanding people.
So the malcontents,
the introverts,
the autistic people,
they all went here.
The people who like people
went into sports betting.
Now what happens if
you're sports betting
and you're successful?
What happens?
Well certainly in those
days, they hire you.
Right?
They want you.
Great, hey, you're winning?
We want to take
advantage of that.
We'll pay you a salary.
You bet for us.
And then the way they
would pay you, by the way,
is they would let
you make bigger bets.
And so you become part
of the organization.
And pretty soon, you're running
your own bookmaking operation
and so on.
So these are social people.
These are Bayesian people.
These people are
betting on frequencies.
betting on people.
Both of them are learning
skills and techniques
that nobody taught
in a classroom, that
were totally generations ahead
of what statisticians were
doing in academics, what people
were doing in econometrics,
anything like that.
These people were because
these people had to.
It only worked if you're right.
You're betting every day.
Smartest people in the world
are spending every waking moment
trying to find a way to beat it.
I did some of both of these.
I also did some poker.
I was mostly a poker player.
Poker is kind of in between.
OK, you've got
some cardplay kind
of thing, shuffle
reading, things like that.
But you've also got to know
something about people.
Not as much as a guy
doing sports betting.
You don't have to predict
actions of thousands of people.
But you do got to be
able to look around
the people at the table
and figure some stuff out.
You've got to be able
to get invited to games.
to collect from losers.
You've got to be able to avoid
arrest or getting cheated
or beaten up and
stuff like that.
So we were kind of in between.
So a lot of people I know
from those days-- this
was the '70s, '80s, early '80s--
a lot of people stayed at it.
But a lot of us, having
honed our skills and figured,
OK, now we think
we know something.
I've been playing
poker since I'm 14.
I've had moderate success in
beating casino games and sports
betting.
I've had some really
strong success at poker.
I have some confidence, right?
I don't just think
I know something.
And the reason I believe it
is I've went to the places
where you test that
stuff and walked away
with people's money.
So a lot of us
went into finance.
So this is really now we're
talking about the early '80s.
The people who
like casino games,
they like secretive
little hedge funds.
They wanted to invest
their own money.
There are only a few
wealthy investors.
As soon as they
could, they wanted
to pay off their investors
and just be by themselves.
And some of this really
brilliant stuff [INAUDIBLE]
fairly narrow focused.
They had to like pick some
narrow niche kind of thing
and do it.
Bayesians, these
people were naturals.
These people went
into big bank stuff.
They knew people.
They knew businesses.
They were bank executive types.
And by the way, in these
days I'm talking about,
you left math off your
resume if you wanted
to apply for a Wall Street job.
I'm not kidding.
People thought if
you knew math, it'd
be like you want
to go to the NFL.
You know, the NFL,
they don't want you
if you've got a PhD in math.
It's like they don't
want smart people.
Wall Street did not want
people who knew math.
Some of them understood
that smart people
would be dangerous.
Others just thought that anybody
in math had to be ivory tower
and couldn't possibly
know anything.
But still, once you
got there, these skills
were incredibly useful.
If you'd been five, six years
betting sports successfully,
you know a lot of stuff
about markets and businesses
and how to run
things with people
that some of these
other people would never
learn their whole lives.
These people didn't have to get
a job, but they're problem was,
could they find
somebody to trade with?
Could they get people
to broker for them,
to trade with them, and so on?
So they had a lot
problems with that.
Me, poker players, people
like me, we could get jobs.
We didn't want high level
executive jobs though.
We wanted to run some little
department under the radar
screen.
We'd run a quant trading team.
We do some pairs trading.
We do some quant stuff.
We do structured products.
We did a lot of
that kind of stuff.
We were used to networking--
we were good at that--
but under the screen.
We weren't good at like
showing up in a suit and tie
and being nice to bosses
and things like that.
We weren't good
at raising money,
which is why we had to go
hook up with a big firm.
We liked the fact that a firm
would give us trading capital,
the firm would give us
setup relationships,
so we didn't have any problem
opening up trading lines
and things like that.
But we basically got
to keep what we made,
or we got to keep a
portion of what we made,
which is a way we like to do it.
This is what really
revolutionized Wall Street.
The thing I tell people is,
having lived through this
from the early '80s
to now, it's people
don't understand how
much finance has changed.
An awful lot of
finance is written
as if there's some
continuous history,
some minor technical
innovations,
electronic trading is just a
little bit faster way of people
yelling at each other in a pit.
Well, it's not true.
The entire fundamental
technological basis of finance
has changed, has
completely been redone.
I use the analogy of a digital
camera versus a chemical
camera.
They kind of look the
same-- or they used, now
they're in your phone.
But a few years ago, a digital
camera looked kind of the same.
It runs on battery.
It's got a flash.
It's got a lens.
It's got a shutter button.
People use it for
the same thing.
They take pictures of their
friends, their vacations,
their parties, things like that.
But the technology inside is
entirely, totally different.
If you want to
make a camera, you
hire completely
different people,
use completely
different processes,
the theory is
completely different.
Well, that's the
difference in finance.
And the people of my generation,
the quants in my generation,
are the ones that built that.
And most of it has a
lot more of its genetics
come from sports betting and
betting casino games and poker
than it does from economic
theory of the 1970s and 1980s
era vintage.
For those of you who are
interested in this stuff,
I put a few books here.
I did these in alphabetical
order of title.
I do have couple of
my own books here,
but Beat the Market
by Ed Thorpe.
Just read anything
you can by Ed Thorpe.
A lot of it's
available free online.
You've just got to.
That's a guy who
understands stuff.
James McManus, a friend of
mine, wrote Cowboys Full.
Some of you may remember James.
He made the final table at
the main event of the World
Series of Poker and wrote a
best selling book about it,
which is a lot of fun,
too-- Positively 5th Street.
But this is a history
of poker if that's
what you're interested in.
It's really the only
good history of poker.
This is a really interesting
book, The Economic Function
of Futures Markets.
For about 100 years, people
wrote nothing but nonsense
about futures markets.
And then this guy came along.
He had a PhD, came along, and
wrote a thin book about 1990
that absolutely explained it.
And it's funny, because
after reading nonsense-- just
transparent nonsense about
futures markets all the time--
this guy wrote a book.
And the thing about this
book is it's logical.
It makes sense.
He's got a story.
He's got empirical
evidence for it.
He nailed it.
He explained what
futures markets are.
And nobody ever
paid any attention.
I mean, nobody ever cites it.
Nobody ever reads it.
Whatever.
But if you want to
know futures markets,
this is the guy who explains it.
Fischer Black-- by the
way, this is the hardback
which has a blue cover.
If you buy the paperback
with a black cover,
it has a foreward by me.
So I go for the paperback.
But this is really interesting.
If you're interested
in the time when
I was at Harvard and
hanging around MIT
and talking to people
who were arguing
about this kind of
stuff, Fischer Black
was a very important
part of that.
I knew him pretty
well in those days.
And there's a lot of really
interesting stuff about how
logic and rationality
and mathematics actually
came into finance.
It didn't come in naturally.
It was some eccentric thinkers--
Fischer Black was nothing if
not eccentric-- who did it.
And this book explains it.
A guy by the name of Perry
Mehrling, Perry Mehrling's
a nice guy who wrote another
good book, The New Lombard
Street, that's very interesting
about modern finance.
This is a book by Daniel
Usner, who I do not know.
This kind of covers
the prehistory.
This tells you
what the world was
like in the Northwest United
States before poker came in.
It goes up to, I
think, 1791 or so.
So it's a pre-history.
But it's really
fascinating economics.
There was a really
fascinating economy
in this part of the world.
The pre-modern economy,
but it had within it more
of the design of the modern
economy than if you'd
gone to London or New
York at the same time.
This is a book, another
guy I don't know.
I actually talked
to him a few times
about this book when
he was writing it,
but this is More Money Than God.
It's an excellent story
of the early hedge
funds, a lot of these
people who were coming
from these sorts of
backgrounds, bringing
some mathematics into finance.
It doesn't have a
tremendous insight.
He doesn't get
into the strategies
or the intellectual
ideas behind the things,
but he'll tell you the
stories of the people
and what happened
and stuff like that.
Two books that I--
I sort of did this
as I was coming up with this
and I just pulled up some books.
But there are two
that I left off
that I was thinking
on the train ride
up I should have put on here.
One of them is
called Poker Faces
by a guy named David Hayano.
He's another guy,
knew him in Gardena.
He was a player in Gardena.
He was also working on
his PhD in sociology.
Actually, he called himself
an autoethnographer.
So he was an ethnographer
who studied himself.
And he wrote.
Anyway, he wrote he wrote a
book on Gardena and the poker
economy and what it was like.
I'm actually in the book.
But it really is a great
book, and it really
tells you kind of what the poker
economy was like in the '70s.
I think that was the last
gasp that takes us back.
It was a lot weaker than it
was in the 1840s Chicago.
So it wasn't as
important to the economy,
but it was still there.
You could really see a lot
of the relations, how things
worked, really were there.
I think that's kind of gone now.
You really don't
find that today.
Another one is by a guy, a
friend of mine, professor Phil
Tetlock lock at Wharton.
He wrote a book called
Expert Political Judgment.
And that tells you
a lot about what
the things that drove
me away from basically
how bad experts are
predicting stuff.
And what really drives
you to-- if you're
good at this tough stuff, if
you're a quantitative person,
if you like to make bets, if
you like to back your judgment,
you've just got to
stay away from experts.
You've got to go someplace where
you find out in cold, hard cash
whether you're making
good or bad predictions.
Pokerface of Wall
Street, this is by me.
This covers a lot of
stuff I'm talking about,
the connection between
poker and finance.
And Red Blooded
Risk, also by me,
this tells a lot more about
how people brought ideas
from sports betting and
poker and Casino games
and how that entered
into mainstream finance.
OK, that's what I've got.
Any questions, comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How good was George
Bush and Bill Gates at Poker?
PROFESSOR: I can't really
answer that in the sense that--
to really answer
that, you'd have
to like tracked their
winnings and losing
for long periods of time.
Bill ran a game
in Courier House.
I didn't like the game.
It was a very tense game.
I always got the feeling people
lost more than they wanted to
and it wasn't a
lot of fun to play.
He was certainly a respectable
player at the time.
You also have to
understand, I'm coming
from a slightly
different perspective.
I'm really at this
point one of the best
players in the country.
We didn't really have
ranking back then,
it was kind of hard to tell.
But I would say there were
maybe 100 people in the country
that I would have felt
more or less equal to,
and I wasn't afraid of anybody.
I would sit down at
the table with anybody
and play them kind of even.
So none of these people
where that level.
None of these
people were kind of
serious, professional players.
But in somebody can be a very
competent, careful player.
George Bush was a lot
of fun to play with.
Ran a great game.
I don't think he was too
interested in the money.
I'm not sure.
He didn't seem to be.
Probably more interested in
the connections, by the way.
By the way, that
drove a lot of people.
A lot of people-- I'm
talking about this networking
in kind of this abstract.
See, I'm an introvert.
So for me, it's kind
of this amazing thing
that you can create
these networks.
I'm thinking of them
very mathematical
and have a diagram.
A lot of people are
just wired that way.
They understand on some--
they don't sit down and draw
network diagrams.
They say, I'm going
to play in this game.
I'm going to make some friends.
I'm going to chat
with my friends.
I'm going to buy
a baseball team.
I'm going to be
president, whatever.
It works for them.
And that stuff
never works for me.
I have to think about it.
I have to do this on
an intellectual level.
[INAUDIBLE] I would say
of the people I played
at Harvard at that time,
the two that were probably
the best in my recollection were
Scott Turow, the author, who
was really could have
been a pro level player.
Probably didn't play enough to
do it, but had the instincts,
had the people skills and so on.
And a guy named Lloyd Trefethen
who's a mathematician at Oxford
now and just was a
really good-- actually
taught me a lot of theory.
We talked about
that stuff a lot.
But all this, one thing I
will say in terms of that.
The people at Garden,
the people at Gardena
really were a cut above that.
A pretty good club player
at Gardena, somebody
who just kind of was
playing at the top stakes
and breaking even, somebody
like that was so much
better than the leather
ass Texas road gamblers
who were playing off in
the World Series of Poker
and things like that.
You went to Las Vegas,
and these people just
were not very good at poker.
Now, they were very
good at making money
at poker, which is a
little bit different.
But if you just sat down, if you
just listened to the analysis
they gave for why they
did things when they did,
it was just-- they
believed in luck.
They would make these
arguments that just
made no strategic sense at all.
They weren't even thinking
in terms of what you think
of [? as ?] [? poker. ?] Now,
that had very little to do with
making a living at poker.
One of the stories I like
to tell is there's a story
that's-- I read it
in a book, actually.
I didn't know this at
the time, but three
WSOP winners-- It
might have been
Dolly Brunsen, Sailor Roberts.
Sailor Roberts
was a good player.
He was probably the only one in
that crowd that was really top.
And one other, they used
to drive around Texas
and play in just
local [INAUDIBLE].
OK, 3 WSOP winners playing
in these Texas games
and stuff, just local people.
They should clean up, or they
should make tons of money.
Sailor told me they broke even.
They just weren't really
making money playing poker.
What they were
doing was they were
bag men for betting on
high school football.
So they were going
to these towns,
they were playing some poker.
And then they were
collecting the bets
and moving around and
getting paid for that.
But the poker was a break
even operation for them.
So a lot of people who have
great reputations in the poker
place, lots of colorful stories,
and just you set them down
at a computer, you set them down
at a tournament or something,
they would just be
toast in five minutes.
But the people, the
people in Gardena--
who were much better in
terms of theoretical poker
playing and playing the
game-- we would've been toast
in that tavern in Texas, right?
We would've been beaten over
the head with a pool cue
and left out with the
cows or something.
I don't just mean
we weren't tough.
We weren't tough.
We aren't tough.
We didn't have social skills.
We had just enough
social skills,
some of us-- most of them
didn't even have that.
I was considered pretty social
because I could actually
get a game together of normal
people and collect money
and so on.
Most of these people couldn't.
They couldn't play
with normal people.
And none of us had the kind of
skills that those people did.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You think if
you're a good player,
are you better off making
a big name for yourself
or staying under the radar?
PROFESSOR: That's
hard for me to answer,
because I come from
a strong tradition
of being under the radar.
It was very hard
for me to come up.
When I wrote this book,
this was my first public
acknowledgement.
I mean, people who
knew me knew I played.
Including on Wall
Street-- you know, I mean,
a lot of famous
people on Wall Street
play and play with whatever.
But to sort of
come out in print--
and when I talk
to people, I said,
I'm going to tell a story
about you in the book.
And people who you
would think would
have no problem being identified
as a poker player just
would not let me do it.
But that said, there's a
whole career out there.
I don't know if it's
still true, but there
are people who made fortunes
by being famous poker players.
And the thing I always
kind of wanted to do,
I never liked tournaments.
I don't like casinos.
I played them
sometimes, but I like
playing when I want to play.
I don't like being
told when to play,
and some of these
casinos, the experience
is just so physically
unpleasant,
playing at 2:00 in the
morning and getting bad chairs
or whatever.
But I was tempted by
high stakes poker.
And I always thought that would
be kind of fun to go in there
and play for cash and be
on television and do that.
That was one that I
kind of thought of.
But you also have to think
a little bit-- like I say,
people in AQR have no problem
with me writing the books
and giving talks
like this and so on.
I don't know about me being
actually in poker after that.
That probably would
be a step too much.
So I think it's a choice
you make, who you are.
And I think if you decide who
you are and you're true to it,
you can be successful.
What you don't want to
do is put on a front.
If you put on a front
for something like that,
it can come back to haunt you.
So if you are a celebrity--
I'm just not a celebrity.
I never could be.
I'd never be happy being one.
Nobody's offered to make
me one, but-- and it
wouldn't be right for me.
But if you are cut from that
cloth, you should do it.
Be true to yourself.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you feel
the view of mathematicians
on Wall Street has
changed since [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
perception of what?
AUDIENCE: Of mathematicians.
PROFESSOR: It's gone through--
it kind of goes through.
OK, so first, it
was just laughable.
And let me explain how Wall
Street works, by the way.
Wall Street is sales.
Finance is sales.
All the money in finance always
has, always will be in sales.
A few quants can make
a couple of bucks
on the edges-- a
few billion, even--
but it's just not a lot in
the whole scheme of things.
If you can bring money in,
if you can gather assets,
it's always been rewarded.
So when the early quants
came, the attitude is,
let's say you're
like LOR associate.
People [? know ?] [? that. ?]
O'Brian, Rubinstein,
and I'm blanking.
These are the people who
did portfolio insurance
in the '80s, whatever.
Anyway, so these finance
professors show up,
these quants show up.
What Wall Street is
saying, hey great.
We don't care.
You could astrologers.
You could be
chartists, whatever.
If you're gathering assets
and you're giving it to us
and paying us
commissions to trade it
back and forth, if you're
giving people reason to trade,
we're happy to service you.
And we'll pretend we
like you, and we'll
pretend to respect you.
Whatever, we don't care.
And they really don't.
And so that was kind of the
attitude toward mathematicians.
If you have a way
to generate trades
and to talk people into
trading, great, because we're
just taking a commission.
All we care about is that people
are coming in and doing this.
Then they started figuring
out that, you know, hey,
wait a minute.
These guys aren't
like everybody else.
These guys actually
are making money.
Some of this stuff
really does make money.
That's very, very
difficult for Wall Street
to come to terms with.
There's a New York
Times Magazine article
about Lehman Brothers with Lou
Gluckman and Peter Peterson,
the clash of those cultures--
the shirt sleeve, cigar
chomping trader culture, totally
at odds with the white shoe
investment banking culture
when these two things crashed.
So then people were kind of
afraid of mathematicians,
but also somewhat
dismissive of them.
So then I think it's kind of
mellowed out a little bit.
But I will still say, AQR
is a quant hedge fund.
When we go and do
our credit thing,
the credit counterparties,
the assumption
is nobody can understand
your black box trading.
Now, that's just not true.
I mean, we are very transparent.
We can sit it down.
And certainly any of you could
figure it out in five minutes,
but other people would
maybe take an hour.
But we can lay it down.
Here's what we do.
Here are the eight signals
and we measure these things.
And we add them up
and we find the best
and we buy this
and we short that.
It's a lot simpler than
somebody who's saying,
oh, I'm doing this quantitative
analysis or technical analysis
or fundamental stuff and I'm
thinking about all these 80
factors.
We tell you exactly what we do.
And they always assign the most
junior credit person to us,
because they figure nobody
can understand it anyway,
so why waste somebody who
knows what's going on?
That kind of prejudice you
still find a lot, that somehow
what we do is crazy.
It's a little weird.
Nobody can really understand it.
It seems to kind of work, so
we'll continue to do business.
We'll recommend you.
We'll put our client's
money in you, but not
with the same confidence we
have with a guy who's saying,
I went to the company
and I pounded the tires
and I talked to the CEO
and I shook him and said,
tell me what's
really going on here.
And I understand this stuff.
The biggest problem is
you're quant's not confident.
It's still the case that people
measure your credibility,
how much they believe you,
by how confident you are.
So if I come in and say,
well, I got this model.
It seems to work pretty well.
I think I got a 60% chance that
this trade will make money.
They just think you're-- they
don't know where you're coming
from, what planet.
A guy comes in and says, I'm
sure this is going to work.
It's got to.
I've got all these
87 reasons, whatever.
Now, they don't believe them.
They think it's 51% just like.
But they expect
him to be confident
and they understand that.
So I think that's
the biggest problem.
If you want to be a
quant and you really
want to be honest about
your confidence for things,
it is shocking to people
how little you know.
It is shocking to people
that with all this work,
51% is still pretty good.
And that, I think,
is a barrier we're
going to have real
trouble ever surmounting.
A quant can
understand, hey, 51%?
Enough bets, you can
be a casino raking
in the money in roulette.
That's great.
Non-quants have problem
with that concept,
which is why they're playing
roulette without the glasses.
OK, we--
AUDIENCE: We don't
have enough time.
PROFESSOR: Well, thank you
very much for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]